can walk him to this video playing
physic 2007 turkey Bishop Bishop g4
that's a very rare move I would um maybe
maybe maybe yeah I mean this looks
almost unplayable for black you had a
son play will actually I can just take
be seven or does he take before then
yeah very hard to believe that all this
is possible for black if here
our d for maximal different I must play
D for you I took took mia took me some
some time to to to to get it right this
is that the right length you cannot take
with the porn with queen of seven Bishop
takes I take b7 now this this should win
outright with Bishop b5 in the mix and
94 I play Queen a4 check and this should
win 0 as well okay I hope this really is
the stroke that decides the game because
you simply cannot play I mean even in
this lab we should be a fire that's
almost unplayable until you granted me
our tempo and I cannot believe that this
should be working so i don't really see
something if it takes me five I will do
what exactly yeah probably take on f5
there's still be seven hanging yeah okay
maybe this is not maybe at least you can
can can play more museum what exactly is
the best way to go
yeah even Queen B 7 s interesting but
this should be this should be okay I'm
also threatening made on f7 still so he
probably needs to diggie five
yeah I don't see my txt five is the only
move anyway what exactly is like
considering here yeah okay check and
just take now under seven what is he
thinking about 94 here okay
okay the take f8 this night is not going
to return you will play nicely too can
you all night a one now that's not great
going to e5 and then having this check
is not really not really great I guess
yeah it's um it's an exchange sacrifice
yeah no way to to rescue the night okay
so what about some easy moves King King
you want I can you want to look strange
okay now I'll play this this simple so
simple line but this is far better than
I expected for black mmmm interesting
maybe it's six MOS player very strange
exactly really for this move what is the
sky here arcades and I would account
it's not an obvious cheetah account okay
okay might have considered Bishop before
but still slow seems very strange okay
jack is in the D file
looks a bit tricky how would you see
keep material here there should be five
maybe yeah all this is very strange
afternoon look see one now now this
leads check to a somewhat challenged
game but still it feels strange that
that we got to go to this pier your form
check check now getting to d3 check one
minute left now that's really a strange
game very strange game I still here
still should be better to be honest it
was rookie 54 he cannot go rook c3 here
I don't think so check Justin I tell it
I happy seven here time morning
black forfeits due to this connection
yeah I don't know sometimes you almost
expect that yeah but still I don't I
don't get get why black was still on the
board I hear you for as the wind and
there was something with a form that's
that's much better him that's that's
that's that's better you now this is
completely cook Jacky wrong it goes here
then Bishop c4 is excellent yeah that's
that's even even better okay this is
probably not bad but some of the game
continues and it shouldn't be form
earlier was even better and ta Queen B
seven seems better but okay that's
really strange look at--look at that
this is working here I have the computer
says not afraid wins okay let's check
this night see to check in d2 yeah and
ok wants to give this away and then it
will track the the night here yeah what
can I say I computers right I will win
the night and then I've got two pieces
and and the pond for the rook which is a
excellent of course yeah this is just
winning I i also have miscounted a bit
here ok this this keeps something but
it's not like winning that's let's just
amazing b5 though is track well then
this this is winning again again it goes
here and play this one probably
threatening to take and play Bishop
reform
plus five okay and this is also winning
yeah he will lose a piece is tied up in
the center okay I didn't see that only
this shot but this is not winning it's
the loan check quite a good chat game
but and computer gives look d3 here hmm
intending books you on check check check
yeah does the system some kinks before
does not help chatter on and rook c8 is
just wrong i meanwhile our you six is
not Luke see chance just losing muster
me must play something else g6 and then
we have this stash a position like this
but this could easily be a win just just
like that because of the space at want
to GI white is winning this out again it
says too much I can go here and and use
my myspace advantage FF some have enough
from Tempe and reserve as well this is
winning yeah it was it was completely
unnecessary to to allow most of that he
can play something that Jeff for example
and this is now a success it's not so
great in comparison because he just
stops my king it's still a bit better
for rose against three but probably
probably is the draw okay the cleanest
way was to think a moment here and play
you form after that black is just
exploding
what I was referring to at the beginning
of the game was this year in the Slav
even this is very problematic for black
and he granted me a good temper with 95
so the sum cannot really be a be viable
alright thanks for watching